they're trying to keep themselves warm
surrounded by their own waste dozens of
Syrian refugees have taken shelter in an
abandoned Factory near the Serbian
Hungarian border aiming to climb this
fence the Gateway into the EU but
heavily armed Smuggler gangs are
controlling the Border region regularly
clashing with each other 10 days ago a
20 year old migrant was shot in the
chest during a conflict between Moroccan
and Afghan Smugglers out of fear for
police and Smugglers the Syrian men
don't want to be identified
we tolerate everything here the colds
hunger and problems with police but our
problems have got more complicated
because of Afghans and Moroccans and the
conflict between them we are peaceful
people we just want to live a peaceful
life
after pressure from the EU Serbia raided
several camps and tightened its
visa-free policies but Sasha dragulio
who has investigated the smuggling gangs
says the government is only paying lip
service to Brussels
so they are saying one thing officially
to the EU officials maybe but they're
they're closely collaborating and
tolerating these groups my research my
investigation showed that there are many
links with the Serbian police and
Security Services with the Smugglers
he says he found evidence Smuggler's
bribe Border Police to allow people
climb the fence the interior Ministry
did not respond to a request for comment
after the fans failed to stop migrants
and refugees from entering the European
Union Hungary has now decided to
increase defense by one meter but
researchers say the fence has created a
dangerous market for Smugglers who have
put vulnerable people escaping war and
poverty at risk human rights lawyers say
measures put in place since 2015 to stop
smokers have not solved the problem I
still cannot understand how after these
seven years the countries have failed to
understand that this practices will
titled as preventing illegal illegal or
regular migration combating organized
crime human trafficking on human
smuggling
is failing because the trafficking and
smuggling is flourishing the more
restricted measures we introduce at the
borders the prices of smart money will
increase a high price these Syrian men
and many others like them continue to
pay for the possibility of safety and a
better life step fast and Al Jazeera in
Northern Serbia